So, we're here to talk about uh
deploying AI models in the edge in, you know, the
world's largest cloud conference.
So that's gonna be fun.
I'm gonna start off with a, with a
question that I want some of you all to guess.
Um, you know, every time you take a
picture on a smartphone, um, does
anybody want to guess how many AI models runs
while you take that picture?
Someone said 10.
OK. Anybody else?
You said 4?
40. OK.
Anybody else?
OK, good. There's only one wrong answer, which is 0.
Nobody gave that answer.
But it's in, it's in the 20 to 30 range. So
there's a significant number of models that
run in that, uh, and so both of you are not too
far off. Uh, there are a significant number
of models that runs on a device
every time you take a picture. Um,
and, you know,
an average smartphone has about 1000
or so, uh, models that are on there.
Uh, and we have over 100,000 applications
in, in a smartphone app app store
that uses AI.
But it's not just phones,
uh, you also have it all over the place
with cars. So,
pretty much all of your ADIS systems are running,
um, on device AI,
um, you know,
smart, smart parking assist,
uh, any kind of like, you know, blindspot
assistance, those kinds of things all use sensors
and AI on the device.
Uh, you also have drones, you have robots, uh,
and you have PCs as well, a lot of, uh,
your PC applications end up using AI
on the device, so.
I mean, the, the, the obvious question is, uh,
why do it on the device, when you have access to
a cloud with
virtually unlimited compute,
why do it on the device, right? And,
um, the primary reason I've, I've
seen people do it, um,
is for the overall snapiness of the
experience. So,
certain things just can't be done uh
by sending information to the cloud and back,
and it's much snappier, much quicker, much
more efficient.
To do it on the device. And
over the years as the device packed more and more
uh compute, you can do more and more sophisticated
things on those devices.
So, latency is a big reason why people do it.
Um, there's another one which is
uh cost. Um,
I was just recently talking to a gaming company
who said they had like a nine-figure bill
for doing AI on the devices. Well, it turns out
you have gaming consoles that have virtually,
you know, you know,
Probably tens of flops that are available there for you
to use. Um, and you can do pretty
sophisticated things on it. So you can offload the
cost to, uh, the
consumers' devices. So cost is also a big thing.
And, and, uh, there's also privacy,
which is a, which is a big factor where you have
everything that stays in the device,
you know, everything that happens on the device stays on the
device, as the way saying goes.
So that, that privacy is also a
big reason why people do this. So,
So today we're going to talk about
how you can get some of your applications
that do
AI on the device.
And
the, for the, for the largest time,
what we saw was developers found
it pretty challenging to take models of a
train in clouds.
And get them running on, you know, on various
different devices that have different architectures
in them and get the best out of the device.
So this process was pretty onerous and over
the last 3 to 5 years,
uh, we at Qualcomm, we've streamlined
that entire process, so you can train your models in the
cloud. And we've built a ton
of automation systems that you can leverage today
completely for free.
Um, you point your models at the
automation and you can
Then get a model that you can deploy
on the device.
And we've streamlined this so that it takes just a
few minutes for you to get something compatible for the
device and something you can run on the device.
Uh, so today, we're gonna walk you through that
process, um,
where we're gonna,
you know, showcase what it's like
to build and deploy a custom
AI application on a bunch of devices.
Obviously, the training process is, uh,
you do it in the cloud. Many of you are familiar with Sagemaker.
We're not gonna go too deep into that, but the
idea is you can use your existing training tools as
is, you don't need to do anything sophisticated or
different. Uh, and then
you get to the stage where you take the model that was
straight in the cloud and you, you optimize it for the
device. Again, that uses a system that we
provide free of cost to all our developers. It's called
Q Qualcomm AI Hub.
Uh, and then once you've, uh, you
know, have an optimized model, we,
uh, we have another system that is available
for you called Edge Impulse, which allows you
to take those models and create this kind
of deployment pipelines that you can use
to deploy on real devices,
um, using other AWS services
like Greengrass, IT Core, Bedrock, and so
on. Uh,
and we'll walk you through that entire journey
of training the model from the cloud
to deploying live on the fleets.
And this is roughly speaking,
uh, the architecture diagram.
Uh, there's a lot of stuff going on there. Um, we'll
go over that step by step,
um, starting with the seven
steps that are in the bottom listed out for you. There's
the strain, optimize,
prepare, deploy, run, and monitor.
It's, it's technically 6 steps. Um,
so we'll go over each of these steps, uh, involving
different services that all seamlessly plug
with each other.
And the nice thing is that
you can do most of these steps without
needing a complicated device sitting on your
desk, because there are lots of device
farms that that abstract away
the complications of having these devices. We make
them available to you through the cloud as well.
So you can do all your development and testing
through your normal work environments and then finally
see the results live.
OK, so the first step is, uh, you know, training
your model. You can use Sage Maker or pretty much
any training service that you use, whether it's,
uh, AWS provided or not.
Uh, you can train, uh, models with,
uh, in, in this, in these environments. You have
enterprise security, you can bring your own data,
you can manage training jobs, and,
and what's nice about this is that once you're
done with the training process, you can
get an output which is an Onyx model or a Pytouch
model. It is pretty standard open
source format that is completely compatible
with the on-device stack.
So really the connection between what you do
in the cloud and what you do on the
edge
is the Onyx model format
or the Pytosh model format, whatever you're comfortable
with. So,
let's say in the first step, uh, you're going
through a training process.
Um, and today we're, we're actually going
through an application that involves,
uh, cameras in a factory,
which you'll hear more about from our second
speaker,
um, where we have defect detection.
So, let's say you're training a model, you use Sage
maker, you collect some data
for determining defects, and then, uh, sorry,
for, you know, doing whatever you need to do.
Uh, you train that model and you're good to
go. And then you go to our, uh,
our service, which is called Q Qualcomm Air Hub, um,
as I mentioned, something freely available.
And what it is, is basically a,
a fully automatable service,
which, which lets you to point,
uh, which allows you to point at
a train model.
And then you pick a device,
depending on what device you're deploying to. So, it
could be a mobile application or it could be
an IOT application, which is what we're going to show you right
now, or it could be
something in an automotive application as well.
And once you pick that device and you say,
OK, I'm deploying this model on this device,
uh, the Edge, uh, Edge AI typically
there are many different runtimes people use to
deploy the model on the actual
Device. So, some people use
Tensorflow, some people use, um, you
know, Onyx runtime, there's executorch,
there's also the Qualcomm AI stack if you want to do
something super native.
So you can just pick your runtime
and say, hey, here's the model that I've
trained. This is the device that I care about, this is the runtime
that I care about.
Now, go, right? And then what happens
is we'll, we'll optimize the model for that
particular configuration, we'll do all the conversion
that's needed, all the optimization that's needed,
and the, at the end of it, you'll get an output.
That you can, you can be sure
will run on the device.
And, and the reason you can be sure is because
as part of this, this, this service,
what we offer is a cloud
of devices that are plugged in.
To our cloud, and we'll do a simulation
on those physical devices so that we can
tell you exactly how fast it's going to run,
uh, how much memory it's going to consume,
and, um, and any kind
of accuracy issues if you hit,
uh, we also can check that for you. So,
everything that you typically need to do to take a model that's
trained in one environment, like the cloud,
and deploy in a different environment, which is the edge,
we do all of that in an automation. So it should
take you just a few minutes to,
to go and do that.
Um, and with that, uh, I'm
gonna introduce our next speaker who, who'll
walk you through the process of now that you
have a trained model,
how do you actually go deploy it,
uh, on an edge device and make
sure you can run and deploy
in a live environment.
So, we'll walk you through that briefly.
Perfect.
And before I move on to step 3, I'll just
briefly introduce myself. So I'm Ashman,
and I'm a solutions engineer at Edge Impulse,
and Edge Impulse was, uh,
we joined forces with Q Qualcomm earlier this
year. So I'm actually a Qualcomm engineer now,
and, uh, I've been in the semiconductor
industry for over 10 years based in Austin,
Texas,
and what I do day to day is I
help our real world customers.
Build real world AI applications.
So that's what I wanna show today
how to build this real world
edge AI application that's capable
of running in real time and really fast on
any type of edge device and the edge device that we're
focusing on today is um a
Qualcomm processor.
So let me jump into step 3, which is
preparing the deployment in Edge
Impulse. So right now what you heard from Krishna
was you, you trained the model in
SageMaker, right? You have a hardware optimized
model through Q Qualcomm AI Hub,
and now what you wanna do is you wanna bring
that model into Edge Impulse. And
what is Edge Impulse?
Edge Impulse is a platform that allows
you to build real world applications.
It can be developers. It can be enterprises,
it can be any type of data. In our case
we're gonna show computer vision.
And you can deploy it onto
CPUs, GPUs, uh, MCUs
as well.
But let me, let me jump in and show you one of our features
that we have in Edge impuls called BYOM,
which stands for bring your own model.
So what we do is we take the
model file, it can be the Onyx file or TFlight
as Krishna was mentioning,
and we bring it into our platform.
And what this allows us to do is
you, you bring in your model and
now you can actually develop and generate
an HML package
so we, we walk you through the pipeline, we get you
a model that's hardware optimized.
It doesn't require you to
have any type of dependencies. You don't have to worry about Python
dependency how it's fully, uh,
kind of self-contained so you can really
bring it into your hardware and be confident
that's gonna run,
uh, fully sufficiently and hardware
optimized.
And our platform lets you walk, uh,
it steps you through the process, so it, it shows you,
uh, it lets you choose what output formats,
um, it lets you bring in some sample
data so you can
eye check and, and make sure that your model passes
the eye test
and once you're happy with the model,
uh, you can do which is on, uh, on the right
side which is deploy.
So we have
a wide array of what you can
deploy on and because our
device is the 6490, a Qualcomm
processor. Uh, we can choose
that easily in our, in our UI.
So once you have the actual
model,
the next step is to.
Deploy the model so you've
generated your model file now how do you get it onto
your fleet of devices, right? So
the use case that we've been talking about is pill
defect detection so.
Imagine you have a whole factory
floor or multiple factory floors that
all have
conveyor belts and they're pills going down the conveyor
belt and you wanna go and put your model
onto each one of these devices.
Now you could individually go
and and update the firmware of all of these
models, right, and
individually go put update the model.
But obviously that's time consuming
and that's also very expensive so
what we can utilize is uh AWS
IUT Greengrass which allows you to
deploy onto your entire fleet of
devices
so it requires 3 steps,
um, and if for those of you all who are familiar
with IOT Greengrass, you might
see these images and.
Uh, resonate with them,
but the first step is you actually install
Greengrass on your Edge device and because
we're using a Q Qualcomm processor, it's running
Linux OS.
In our case, uh, Qualcomm Linux,
it's actually really easy to install Greengrass.
It's just a couple of dependencies that you have to install
and, and we have instructions, uh,
online for all of this. So feel free to ask me, and
I can, I can point you in the right direction.
And uh one note, even if you're using
another OS like Ubuntu, it's exactly
the same steps as well so we really allow you
to choose uh whatever you want to use
and then the next step is customizing
your YAO recipes and what
is this and why are, why are we doing this?
Well, what are we trying to deploy,
right? Like we, we wanna deploy
something that will allow us to get the model and
also test the model on our Edge device,
and Edge Impulse helps you do that
with a tool, with a software tool called
Edge Impulse Linux Runner.
So what the Yama recipe
is setting up is, is setting how to get
this edge impulse Linux runner on all
of your devices
and once you set that up, you create
the component, you put it in an S3 bucket,
and, uh, the, the final step is actually
deploying it on your device
and something that I was very pleasantly
surprised about, uh. With using AWS,
all of this stuff, all of these steps that you see right here
were done through the management console. So
when I was setting up the demo
and for those of y'all who stopped by the Q Qualcomm
booth, you might have seen this, this pill defect detection
running live.
Um, all of these steps, uh, the,
the green grass steps were all set up in the
AWS management console,
and it's super intuitive, super easy,
and you don't actually have to
run some complicated scripts
locally just, just to get up and running.
OK, so now we've talked about
generating the model
and now we've talked about deploying the model.
Now the next step is actually running
the model that is actually on your device.
So why do we wanna do this?
Well, in our use case,
we don't want to
just you wanna be able to
do something with your models, right? You wanna have him
do some action. So,
uh, what we wanna do here is
run the edge and bolt cynics runner which I
talked about in the previous slide.
And what this allows you to do is essentially
get two types of outputs, and it really depends on
what you're trying to do at that moment in time. So
one of the types of output is just simple
text bounding box inference in our use
case because we're trying to see uh
where the pills are, right? So you can see the bounding
boxes where the normal pills are and where the bounding
boxes, where the defects are.
And
that eventually we will send up to the cloud
for further monitoring and analysis,
but before I jump to that part, um,
I also wanted to quickly note that the Linux
runner also lets you visualize
all of your, your inference results,
right? So on the bottom right what
you just saw was just
local processing, right? So you're not actually
taking images, having the video stream,
and sending it up to the cloud.
What you're actually doing is running the model
on the edge locally and.
If I
kind of go back and and play this animation
again you'll you'll see just how fast
this model is running, right? So this
is honestly not just a
nice to have in a manufacturing use
case that we have,
but it's, it's a necessity to be able
to have a model that's running so
fast and when you have some crucial
aspects, let's say like you, you have a,
a, a large defect trend, you wanna be
able to stop your assembly line
and, and have a technician go check it out so.
It's really important to to not always send all
your images up to the cloud at some point.
All right, so now we've discussed training the model, we've
discussed, uh, deploying the model and now
running the model, and now the, the
next step and almost the
pretty much the final step is actually doing
something with this data. So you're monitoring,
you're analyzing.
And for, for any of the, the AWS
experts out out in the audience,
once you get it onto some AWS
component, you can really do anything
with it, right? So in our case what
we did was we sent the data,
uh, uh, pretty much the, the inference
results in text format
to AWS IUT core.
And once it was an IOT core,
we were able to publish it,
um, add it into a time stream, uh, database,
and then from there we just, we, we showed a Grafana
dashboard that was querying from this database,
and that's what we showed at the booth for anyone,
uh, who stopped by.
Um, but, but what this is really there
to show is it, it's up to you, it's up to the
use case,
um, and it's up to the customer to decide what
they wanna be able to do. So in our
use case we're trying to find defects,
right? How many there are, where they
are, and is it trending in the right
direction or wrong direction. So by
seeing the, the graphic on the bottom right
you're seeing that we're, we're, we're having a decrease
in the defect rate.
All right, so
we've gone through all of the steps, right? So we, we
started with the training, we went to optimizing,
we prepared the model on Edge and
pulse, we deployed and ran it using
green grass,
and now we're also monitoring. So
with that we've completed the pipeline
from kind of. Start to finish
and let me just kind of go through a
couple of the kind of the the learnings
that we found.
So one is we reduced
the training time
uh by using Amazon Sage Maker and as
Krishna mentioned
by using SageMaker you can train your model. In our case it
was computer vision.
And also
going from Sagemaker to Q Qualcomm AI hub,
we were able to achieve 20 times faster
throughput by optimizing the model. So
the whole point of AI Hub was
to optimize your model for your specific hardware
and also with AI
Hub and then Edge Impulse we're also able to
create a, a model that was so efficient
that it.
Had just a few milliseconds of latency,
so the inference speed was really fast, and
we were able to see it in, in the, the
graphic in the last slide where you see the pills
being defect, uh, detected
for defects in, in real time.
And then finally, thanks to the integration
of uh Greengrass and Edge Impulse,
we were able to deploy
the entire fleet of devices
that you have set up in ADWS with
your models.
And
for, for final takeaways which what what
I wanna leave you with is, um,
kind of just what is the flow,
what, what do we actually see today?
One was obviously we, we started with
Sagemaker,
um, that's really speeds up your
development time and, and we have examples
for all of this on our websites and I'll, I'll send you
some links and QR codes, uh, shortly
so you can, you can check out how to get set up with your
own use case,
um. We took the model
we had AI hub really optimize the
model. We had Edge Impulse
take that model, put it into a more
easily deployable, uh, artifact
that the Edge Impulse Nex runner was able to
deploy onto multiple devices using
Greengrass. And with that you
can see how
we really use the best of both worlds, right? We
used Q Qualcomm technologies to show
that we have.
AI we have called Kameahub we have edge Impulse to really
optimize your model
and and get it something that's really edge
optimized so you can run it really fast and
then we also use AWS technologies
to, to take advantage of their cloud infrastructure
to, to get the model out into
the real world and then
not just get the model out there but also start
monitoring and analyzing and,
and doing some real world use cases with it.
So with that, that, that concludes
our presentations and.
Um, here are the QR codes that I promised, so
if you want to get up and ready
with, um, edge impulse,
uh, there's a, there's a.
Our landing page for uh a free sign up that you
can go and test out and
one other thing to note is right now
what Krishna and I talked about was a computer
vision use case,
right? But
let's say you have another use case you've got some like
audio-based use case or motion-based use
case. What you can do is upload
whatever data set that you have or your customer has
into our portal. We'll train a model
similarly what
what, what I showed you for computer vision, but for
the other data sets,
and we can kind of walk you through the whole pipeline
just like I showed.
And then similarly, we have uh the landing page for
Qualcomm AI hub as well.
So, yeah, with that, uh,
that concludes our presentation.
Thank you.